I'm Dwight Howard and my favorite movie
is Finding Nemo man I probably seen that
200 times maybe more because I used to
watch it all the time I can relate to
the movie a lot because my dad is the
same way
how Nemo's dad is now what's the one
thing we have to remember about the
ocean it's not sink that's my boy it's a
similar situation my mom she lost seven
kids and I was one of the ones that was
not supposed to make it also and I end
up making it you know I'm a blessing and
be here that's why I can really relate
to that movie and we'll never let
anything happen to you I'm not evil I
don't have a little flipper I love that
movie because all the different
characters and stuff like that hello my
name is Bruce hi Bruce my name is Bruce
hi Bruce fish are friends not food fish
are friends not food I'm in high school
and I'm about to enter the NBA Draft
and I remember being at the McDonald's
game and you know all the guys there
used to always make fun of me because
fighting me was my favorite movie and I
would always say just keep swimming so
any time anybody saw me and I was in a
bad mood I wasn't smiling this ain't
away just keep swimming and then
everybody would say just keep swimming
just keep swimming what do you do you
swim I would say for me coming from
where I came from you know there's this
small school you know this atmosphere of
love you know where it was just us then
I go into this world it's the NBA once I
stepped across that stage and they
called my name and I put their head on a
representative my whole life changed
Dwight Howard
[Music]
Southwest a lot of Christianized Nobita
y'all pick congratulations going on it's
really like stepping off into the deep
end of the ocean you go from this little
platform to this big world like Nemo did
and then you have a father who was
basically he hasn't been anywhere either
you know and this is his only son it's
the only thing that he has of his life
you know he's like I gotta protect him
at all costs be cheap then you have a
son he's like I want to go out and
experience everything you know it really
meant a lot to me and it kind of just
helped me with my situation at home with
my dad you know and understanding him
more just from this movie you know no
matter what happens in life no matter
how far I stray away or whatever I do
he's gonna always love me and be there
for him I'm Dwight Howard and I love
movies
[Music]
you
[Music]